the threat of violence is now too close
to home
days of fighting have left many Sudanese
desperate and Afraid
thousands of people are leaving Hartung
we were told to get out anyone who is
able to leave but we can't just sit
around we need to make a living
the Army and paramilitary Rapid support
forces blame one another for breaking
several ceasefires in recent days the
streets of the capital are seeing the
effects of conflict a lot of reports and
and pictures from people also there's a
lot of dead bodies
some of them that our military and some
of them are civilians some of them got
recognized by the peoples who are there
from the neighborhood but some of them
were not
during the Lal indan fire some people
venture out to stock up on food and
water but supplies are limited
and the United Nations weren't a
humanitarian catastrophe is looming
many of the country's best hospitals are
in hartum where the most intense battles
are taking place there are a few
hospitals treating the injured and the
number of doctors is limited there's a
lot of overcrowding that's even though a
lot of wounded can't make it to the
hospitals because of the fighting
for some leaving isn't an option at
least not yet
it's also real you see children watching
cartoons at home against a backdrop of
air strikes I was walking outside with a
friend who's hosting me and we heard the
sound of an attack I asked her if indeed
it was an airstrike and she said calmly
yes it feels strange that people are
growing used to this type of situation
after years of political instability
coups and fighting Sudan was on the
verge of transitioning to a civilian-led
government those plans are now on hold
again
despite going through several Civil Wars
since its independence the capital had
remained stable and far from the scenes
of fighting and its residents forced to
flee but it's now where sounds of heavy
artillery fire and explosions can be
heard throughout the day and where it's
becoming harder for people to get water
food and other basic necessities
and as thousands of people leave their
homes in search of safety there are
fears the violence could spread Beyond
Sudan's borders
people Morgan Al Jazeera cartoon